you smell that
i can smell that underwater well don't
look at me
let's get out of here agreed
[Music]
the smells of the universe are not
universal listen you smell something
different objects in space like comets
planets moons
gas clouds each have their own
distinctive aroma
ooh i love the smell of the universe in
the morning me too
we're all watching the expanse right if
you're not start immediately it's the
best sci-fi show on tv
and it's based on a series of novels
which are equally awesome and i will
link below
anyway the expanse describes the moon as
having a gunpowder stink
and i remember reading that and thinking
what a cool description and it made me
wonder
how do they come up with that does the
moon really smell like gunpowder turns
out it does
for this video we're going to assume the
moon landing was not faked
we are going to assume the moon landing
was real
you believe anything when recalling the
smell of the moon
apollo 17's jack schmidt said everyone's
impression of the smell was that of
spent
gunpowder now this is strange because
the makeup of lunar dust
is completely different than gunpowder
moon regolith is made up of silicon
dioxide glass created by billions of
years of meteor impacts it also contains
iron calcium and magnesium but modern
gunpowder
is a combination of nitrocellulose and
nitroglycerin so why the similarity
well nobody really knows but it could be
a sign that moon dust is chemically
active so how does the smell even happen
well there are a couple of theories one
is called the desert rain effect you
ever notice that awesome smell that
happens after a summer rain
that smells called petrichor from the
greek words petra meaning rock or stone
and the word iker which is the fluid
that flows through the veins of the gods
on earth plant oils accumulate on rocks
during dry periods along with another
compound geospin which is a metabolic
byproduct of bacteria found in soil
during rain the oils and geosmin are
released into the air causing that
distinctive smell of petrichor
and if there's lightning sometimes you
could sniff a little ozone obviously
there are no plants on the moon
but there's still stuff right the
molecules trapped in the dry moon dust
may have been
activated by contact with the moist air
in the lunar module
just like petrichor and the desert rain
effect another theory is solar winds
hot solar winds of hydrogen helium and
other ions
buff at the moon's surface and may
become trapped in the dust
when the ions are dislodged such as by
an astronaut's
footsteps then come in contact with the
warm air inside the lunar module
they evaporate that's possible these
ions were brought into the cabin
producing the odor either way the smell
didn't last long by the time the moon
dust made it back to earth it was
completely odorless
so we'll have to take nasa's word for it
but space itself may even have a smell
astronauts returning from spacewalks
have reported smelling burnt metal or
burnt meat
and no one really knows for sure what
this is but it could be molecules of
metal leeching off onto spacesuits
then oxidizing when it comes into
contact with actual
humidified air now i think that's super
interesting so
let's work our way around the solar
system and see which planet smells like
toasted almonds and which planet smells
like
the porta potty on the last day of a
renaissance fair that reference was
oddly specific
mercury mercury is the smallest and
closest planet to the sun named after
the greek god hermes and translated into
latin as mercurius the messenger of the
gods
and mercury contains a lot of sodium
which doesn't have much of an odor but
there's also a lot of silicon dioxide
present
like the moon so we assume the smell
would be
gunpowder just salty gunpowder venus
venus is the second planet from the sun
named after the roman goddess of love
and beauty
when they named the planet they clearly
couldn't smell it venus has a thick
atmosphere mostly carbon dioxide
there's also heavy clouds of sulfuric
acid that combination makes venus smell
like a burnt match
and rotten eggs mars is the fourth
planet from the sun
and the second smallest planet in the
solar system being larger than only
mercury
named for the roman god of war mars is
often referred to as the red planet
because of the iron oxide on the surface
now despite what matt damon would tell
you
mars doesn't have much of an atmosphere
since mars lost its magnetosphere
billions of years ago
solar winds are constantly stripping
away atoms from the outer layer
but what atmosphere there is contains
methane formaldehyde
carbon monoxide and sulfur dioxide the
martian sand
smells like rusty metal because that's
what iron oxide is
combining the odors of the surface with
the orders of the air and mars is
probably going to smell like the exhaust
of an old car with a bad catalytic
converter
it's basically the same stuff and yeah
you can't breathe that
i'm definitely going to die up here
jupiter jupiter is the fifth planet from
the sun
and the largest in the solar system it's
a gas giant named after the king of the
roman gods a jupiter's atmosphere is 5
000 kilometers thick and actually has
multiple layers each with slightly
different smells
the outer layers have a lot of ammonia
which smells like horse urine
hello as you move closer to the surface
the atmosphere becomes more sulfuric
smelling like skunk and horse urine the
inner layers
have a high concentration of hydrogen
cyanide which smells like toasted
almonds
and skunk and horse urine and rotten
eggs
satin saturn is the sixth planet from
the sun
and the second largest in the solar
system after jupiter it's also a gas
giant
named after the roman god of wealth and
agriculture now saturn's atmosphere is
hydrogen and 4 helium so not much of a
smell
but there are trace amounts of methane
phosphine
acetylene and ammonia and phosphine can
smell like rotten fish
what so saturn probably smells like dead
fish
and skunk and rotten eggs what's in all
the rat
eggs good question eggs are very high in
two proteins globulin and keratin
when globulin decays a toxic chemical is
released
hydrogen sulfide which has a very potent
sulfur smell
i mean you know it when you smell it and
keratin also has very high levels of an
amino acid called cysteine
which is also full of sulfur hydrogen
sulfide happens to be one of the most
common compounds in the solar system
so rotten eggs everywhere
uranus uranus uranus
please please don't say it that way you
say tomato
i say uranus tomato uranus
potato do you mind all right okay
i couldn't resist uranus is the seventh
planet from the sun
named for the greek god of greek god of
the sky
that's probably the smelliest planet in
the solar system
stop it the upper atmosphere is mostly
hydrogen so not much of a smell
but as you get closer to the surface it
gets pretty ripe
have we uh probed uranus
yes we we have no i hope they were
gentle so
why does uranus smell so bad well the
cloud tops of uranus are made of
hydrogen sulfide that gas responsible
for the foul smell of rotten eggs
and human flatulence
a little lower in the atmosphere you'll
find methane and ammonia
so so uranus smells like a public toilet
it does
neptune named after the roman god of the
sea
neptune is the eighth and farthest
planet from the sun at 17 times the mass
of the earth
it's slightly more massive than its twin
uranus does it smell as bad as uranus
well most of the compounds are frozen in
the atmosphere so
really just hydrogen and helium are
present neptune doesn't have much of a
smell at all
that's too bad i got more jokes no i'm
sure you do
everywhere else a few honorable mentions
dwarf planet pluto is a near vacuum with
nitrogen methane and carbon monoxide
so deadly but odorless one of saturn's
moon's enceladus
is covered in ice but underneath it has
an ocean of liquid salt water
it was recently discovered that plumes
of methanol are ejected from the surface
so it could smell like a martini i'm
steve o and this is the poo
cocktail supreme comets mostly smell
like burnt metal and of course rotten
eggs and lots of asteroids contain
formaldehyde and cyanide so they could
smell like
pickles and marzipan no sounds like what
my ex-wife ate when she was pregnant
you've been married three times huh i
didn't know that
well i had a life before you came along
you know okay okay take it easy
sorry sorry i'm still working through
some things anyway
the center of our galaxy is the dust
cloud sagittarius b2
and in that cloud scientists have
discovered a substance called ethyl
formate
which is the chemical responsible for
the flavor of raspberries and the smell
of rum
so not so bad so here's what we learned
today
what's that the worst smelling thing in
the solar system is
uranus i hate you
[Music]
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj and that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything today do us a favor
give us a thumbs up it really helps out
the channel oh
and whoever makes the best uranus joke
in the comments wins an amazon gift card
i got one you're disqualified until next
time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
hey you know i heard there's a black
hole near uranus
will you stop it